this is the gazipur landfill in Delhi
India it's almost 20 stories high and it
often collapses killing the waste
Pickers that work there last year when
temperatures hit 43° C it caught fire
three times in a month and burned for 48
hours straight exposing the city to
harmful particulate matter this happens
because the organic was
in the landfills decomposes to form
methane a highly flammable and potent
greenhouse gas and as we have more and
more heat waves the problem will only
get worse this landfill in Buenos Iris
causes the pollution equivalent to
roughly 1.4 million cars or the same as
roughly two average size co-fired power
plants landfills like these are major
contributors to climate change because
of the methane they
emit
methane comes from everywhere in the
world but in developing countries
emissions are expected to double by
2050 methane is therefore the global
South climate challenge because it's a
development challenge as poor countries
get richer their demand for food and
consumer goods will increase and so will
the waste they generate if we're going
to keep warming under 1.5° C we need to
reduce methane emissions in half by 2050
but we must do so without getting in the
way of quality of life improvements in
the global South that's why in 2022 I
became the CEO of the global methane Hub
a major philanthropic effort focused on
methane mitigation based out of Santiago
Chile methane doesn't get the same
attention as carbon dioxide does but
it's contributed to nearly half the
warming we've experienced today it's
shortlived so we stop emissions now its
warming effect will soon follow if we
only focus on carbon dioxide emissions
we're only going to get half the
temperature reduction with these next
two decades mitigating methane therefore
is the fastest most efficient way to
reduce temperature within our
lifetime but don't get me wrong this is
not about delaying action on fossil
fuels 40% of methane emissions come from
fossil fuel extraction but today I'm
going to talk about the other 60% that
not a lot of people talk about which is
Food Systems emissions food production
and food
waste I'm a biochemical engineer a
professor and I was formerly the
environment Minister for
chile before I got into politics when I
was a graduate student at the University
of Iowa I'd work with NASA tracking
pollution across continents using
aircraft and satellites when I got back
home I used those same tools to develop
air quality forecasting systems that
helped change the way we did things and
we had a radical drop in air pollution
levels but during my tenure a large
slant CAU fire and it put the whole city
of Santiago under a black cloud of
carcinogenic soot it was an event our
model couldn't predict it was methane
again another landfill nearby smells so
terrible that neighbors protested for
weeks and they were right nobody
deserves to live like that and we could
do something about
it the organic waste in landfills is one
of the most visible sources of methane
literally and Food
Systems food loss and waste is a big
part of the problem 50% of all Food
Systems emissions come from food that
nobody ever eats in subsaharan Africa
37% of all food that's produced is
either lost or wasted either because
there's not enough infrastructure to
store it to transport it or to keep it
from spoiling the other part up ends up
in the trash and when that organic waste
is concentrated in the landfill we can
see the methane this waste emits from
space the NGO carbon mapper is a public
private partnership that's leveraging
technology developed by NASA scientist
to pinpoint methane sources across the
world they started with aircraft and
soon they'll be up in a satellite seed
methane this way contributes to real
mitigation and the Sunshine Canyon
Landfill in Los Angeles is an example of
this Airborne methane data inform basic
operational improvements such as
covering the daily trash with liners
which led to a radical drop in emissions
60% lower emissions and the complaints
from Neighbors
disappeared now we decided to take this
effort
globally and with our colleagues from
RMI the cleaner task force and carbon
mapper we put together the waste map the
waste methane assessment platform which
links satellite information Nos and
local governments to intervene with
other colleagues we're working in the
biggest landfill Hills in the world
including the one you saw in Delhi the
one in Buenos cidis and of course the
city of Santiago where I
live pinpointing methane sources allow
us to stop existing emissions but they
also help prevent new emissions from
occurring too and it starts with organic
waste
diversion we could do a lot of different
solutions like
composting we could do food banking or
we could turn that organic waste into
food like what my dog rusio eats made
from solder flies that grew on food
waste now don't worry I would never feed
my dog anything I wouldn't
eat but food waste is not the only
problem what we eat also has big impact
and in that cows raising cows for dairy
and meat is the single largest
anthropogenic source of methane that's
right cows the scientific ific name for
that is anic
fermentation if you feed an animal low
quality food instead of high quality
food it a lot of that energy doesn't go
to create milk it goes to digestion and
cow burps so an animal in subsaharan
Africa causes five times more emissions
than one in North America per unit of
milk because it's using is usually
eating suboptimal food so improve
breeding feeding and animal w could
reduce emissions and improve income for
Farmers but we have to do a lot more
about cow burp emissions and that's why
we're launching the anic fermentation
research and development accelerator a
$200 million effort that will focus on
reducing livestock emissions and it will
be the biggest effort of its kind you
may have heard some scientists are
feeding algae or seaweed to animals to
change their metabolism to reduce
methane emissions and there's a whole
bunch of Sol Solutions like that but for
each one we have to know is it safe does
it last and how we perform when it's not
in optimal settings like when it's out
in the animal is out in pasture all day
instead of being fed we hope that this
research initiative will deliver the
scientific breakthroughs we need to
reduce livestock emissions and keep 1.5
alive when I was Minister I would often
hear from my colleagues why should we
act on climate change if it was the rich
countries that cause the problem and
it's partly true emissions have
historically come from developed
countries but they're Rising fast in the
developing
world we don't need to follow a path
will need we know will lead to higher
emissions and pollution we could cut
across straight into Sustainable
Solutions but what I heard from
colleagues was based on the premise that
reducing emissions will make our
day-to-day life worse because of all the
things we have to do without but this is
a false narrative and it's not the case
for
methane methane is a global problem but
the benefits are felt where action is
taken vulnerable communities that aren't
exposed to the constant thread of dump
fires or foul
smells landfills that aren't filled with
rotting organic waste that can instead
be turned to food or fertilizer Farmers
that are already under the threat of
climate change could gain income and
resilience because of better more
efficient livestock and rice
production you and
I can't do much to create zero emission
cement or change grids across countries
or continents well some of you can but
not
everybody but 60% of our emissions from
methane come from our food our trash and
our neighborhoods and taking action on
reducing methane now is a big step to
saving the planet and we can start when
we get back home composting our
food we'll see the benefits better
living conditions cleaner air improved
food security right here and right now
thank
you